[Applause]
that's a really bad sign
hey I'm Cale and welcome to your weekly
ticket work from home edition we finally
get to talk about dune that's because
Vanity Fair has released our first look
at Timothy sha'lame and dune he is
playing Paul Atreides a privileged child
who is raised by a powerful family who
is entrusted with the protection of a
valuable asset the film of course is an
adaptation of the classic sci-fi novel
from Frank Herbert and it will be
directed by Denis Villeneuve who we know
from a rival and Blade Runner 2049 this
is also his first time producing one of
his own films and the movie comes out
December 18th if we're in quarantine any
longer my hair is gonna start looking
like Timothy sha'lame it's so weird like
curling around the sideburns and an
other release news James Gunn who will
be directing the third guardians of the
galaxy film and the Suicide Squad said
that neither movie will be delayed due
to the corona virus and both films are
slated to release in 2021
I will now pause so you can do your fist
pump but now on to some newly announced
remakes Stephen King's classic vampire
novel Salem's Lot will be getting a film
adaptation from director Gary Doberman
Gary Doberman is best known for
Annabelle comes home and writing the
screenplay for Warner Brothers it and it
chapter two so I mean they got somebody
who knows their way around some Stephen
King so that's great the classic horror
film Hellraiser we'll also be getting a
reboot David Bruckner is teaming up with
spyglass Media to remake the classic
horror film Ben cons and Luke Petrosky
his writing team on his latest film the
night house will be writing the
screenplay
all right well if you're stuck inside
and you're still looking for something
to watch well that's why we're here
we've got this segment of the show and
we've got a special guest today
Fandango correspondent Niki Novak is
gonna help us find something to watch
Niki what do you got for us I have got a
movie that I missed in theaters in
January but apparently I was one of the
only ones because it made four hundred
and twenty five million dollars at the
box office and that is bad boys for life
now I have to admit I didn't run to the
theater to see this one because I kind
of I saw the first two I think I saw
them a long time ago and if you're like
me and you're like yeah I remember the
franchise it's kind of cool I don't know
if I want to watch it at home this is a
perfect movie for right now because it
is a complete escape it'll make you
laugh it's over-the-top it's produced of
course the first year was directed by
Michael Bay who loves explode explosions
and big action and all that kind of
thing which right now just seems right
it's just great to watch and just lose
yourself in in all the jokes that they
make in-between and I think that's what
really works for this movie I think we
all know Martin Lawrence and Will Smith
have a great chemistry together first of
all he gave me so much 90s nostalgia
watching this movie but the reason why
it really worked for me is nowadays when
we see action movies like I love I love
fast and furious I love Mission
Impossible but these are not necessarily
comedians their action stars these two
reminded me that they're primarily funny
guys that are thrown into an action
movie and the chemistry between them has
been described by Will Smith as magic
and that's exactly what it is I also
love because I think we're all missing
being able to travel and I love
traveling Miami is the third character
in this movie it is such an escape the
blue waters the Sun shines the carefree
attitude just put me in a good mood
highly recommend this one what do you
back Hale my suggestion is happy
deathday now you might have overlooked
this one because you thought it was a
straight horror film but it's but it's
not it's actually more of a comedy it's
going to subvert your expectations on
that and it's well worth your time and
now is the chance to catch up on it it's
about a college girl named tree who gets
murdered but wakes up in her bed and
relives the same day again just to get
murdered again this happens over and
over and over
as she looks for the murderer it yeah
it's basically Groundhog's Day and
Jessica Roth who is the main character
of play Street is incredible she's
hilarious and if you've already seen the
first and you haven't seen it there is a
second one called happy deathday to you
if you haven't seen either I recommend a
double feature they're both fantastic
and the second one man they've got some
high concept ideas but it's so well
worth the watch I was saying earlier
that I watched it on a Valentine's Day
date the second one and we were just
like this whole time like what is going
on looking at other people being like
what what is this it's fantastic
it's hilarious I think it's some levity
that we all need right now but thank you
again so much Nikki thanks for joining
me thank you I know you love props by
the way I do I saw your noodles last
week and guess what I got some Miami
1990s bad red shades for you so let's go
out with this can i watch happy deathday
like this on a date you can't there we
go no there we go I love full nerd with
it whatever and available to watch at
home today underwater gotta get to the
station how do we even get that we walk
we're just gonna walk with insufficient
oxygen across the bottom of the ocean
you'll know what's out there
disaster strikes more than six miles
below the ocean's surface when water
crashes through the walls of a drilling
station led by their captain the
survivors realize that their only hope
is to walk across the seafloor to reach
the main part of the facility but what's
out there
the film was directed by William Ewbank
and stars Kristen Stewart Vincent
Cassell and TJ Miller and available to
watch at home this Friday is Wendy
remember the voice in your head
the one that said speak away
[Music]
the classic story of Peter Pan is wildly
reimagined in this Ben Zeitlin directed
drama lost on a mysterious island where
aging in time have come unglued Wendy
must fight to save her family her
freedom and the joyous spirit of youth
from the deadly peril of growing up
director Ben Zeitlin also auditioned
non-actors during a year-long process to
cast the film
all right everyone now is your chance to
leave us a comment and let us know what
you're watching anything you think we
should catch up on and I will see you
next week
[Music]